but first tonight america's cities they
are in crisis
look at the statistics they're
everywhere rape robbery assault murder
is skyrocketing
in portland the murder rate is up a
whopping 800 percent
in minneapolis it's up by a whopping 56
percent
philadelphia washington d.c los angeles
new york chicago
also now suffering through major spikes
in violent crime
now what do all these cities have in
common one they are all run and have
been for many years by far left
democrats
number two the same democrats that
vilified law enforcement
slashed police police budgets defunding
the police
vowing to defund and dismantle as well
and acting soft on crime policies like
no bail reform
refusing to prosecute people that we
have video
of rioting and looting involved in arson
and other violent criminals
during the summer of 2020 these
democrats they bent the knee to an angry
mob
denied the reality that was playing out
before the entire country
and minneapolis city leaders allowed a
police precinct to be burned to the
ground
in seattle entire city blocks
were seated to rioters and criminals for
weeks
downtown portland was lit on fire almost
every night for months
and all across the country police were
assaulted with bricks
and frozen water bottles and rocks and
molotov cocktails
several other cities experienced arson
looting on a massive scale
look at your screens scenes like this in
santa monica california
they were widespread looting in broad
daylight
in chicago new york los angeles dozens
and dozens of storefronts
smashed and looted in times square over
the weekend a
marine was hit with a stray bullet in
oakland where the city council where
they just voted to defund the police
a gunman tried to rob a camera crew
during an interview with the city's
crime prevention chief
at city hall pretty brazen a few weeks
earlier in san francisco another news
crew was
robbed at gunpoint again in broad
daylight take a look
the car came up here while we're about
to do an interview
three guys jumped out one had a gun put
it up to my face and said
we're taking the camera ford a veteran
journalist said the whole encounter with
a glock in his face
took less than a minute my whole thought
at the moment was
let's be calm let's not get this guy
excited
he's got the gun i don't so you take the
camera it's yours buddy
the violence is out of control and it's
happening in many cities all across the
country
instead of cracking down on crime and
restoring law
and order so we can be safe and secure
and pursue happiness
while police budgets they're getting
slashed officers are now being
restricted they're told to stand back
and stand
down many criminals who loot and riot
and steal
they're not even getting arrested and
most of those that have been locked up
that just quickly let out of jail
and then all charges even with
videotaped evidence has dropped
for example 118 individuals arrested
in new york city during last year's
looting spree
almost every single case was just
dismissed
tons of evidence now after a year of
chaos and violence and mayhem
almost no one in america supports this
insane deep on the police movement
only 18 percent according to a recent
poll and meanwhile a brand new harvard
harris poll shows
an overwhelming majority nearly 70
percent of americans have in fact
a favorable view of police according to
a pew poll minorities
including african-americans are worried
about crime
and opposed cuts to police funding
obviously these are not good numbers for
democrats
that have sat idly by and silent and
spent the last year themselves
vilifying the police deep funding and
dismantling
but tonight the biden administration
well they have a bold new plan they tell
us
unfortunately that plan has nothing to
do with making your city
safer instead the geniuses in the new
administration
they're now accusing republicans they're
saying they're the ones that want to
defund the police
okay i'm not making this up and we've
got the videotape to prove it take a
look
look republicans are very good at
staying on talking points of
who says defund the police but the truth
is they defunded the police
we funded crime intervention and a whole
bunch of other things
part of his announcement is also
ensuring their specific
guidance to communities across the
country to ensure that they have
funding to get more community police
around the country something that was
supported by
the american jobs plan that was
supported that was voted into law by
democrats just a couple of months ago
some might say that the other party was
for defunding the police i'll let others
say that but
that's a piece that's what you call an
outright lie
you could even call it a conspiracy
theory if they actually believe that
crap
and where are the so-called fact
checkers at the washington post or
fake news cnn or politifact uh maybe
they want to
weigh in on this one this might be the
most blatant lie
in in modern american politics but you
don't have to take my
word for it because we actually have
proof it's called videotape
thank god for videotape take a look
yes i support the defund movement
because this is about
the the um investment
in our communities which have
historically been divested one that i'm
actively engaged in in
advocacy for is the reduction of
really truly talking about um the
reduction of our nypd budget and
defunding
a six billion dollar nypd budget this
model
of saying not only do we need to defund
but we need to dismantle and start anew
allows us to really re-imagine
what public safety should look like in
our community you know in in many cities
in america
over one third of their city budget goes
to police
so we have to have this conversation
what are we doing
remember last year democrats they
wouldn't call riots riots
and the same democrats never mentioned
it at the
dnc all that had gone on last summer
kamala harris herself even promoted that
bail fund to get violent criminals out
of jail
during the dnc no mention of last
summer's violent riots even joe biden
himself
he said the police have become the enemy
and he agreed the city should absolutely
redirect funds away from law enforcement
they're now blaming republicans for this
but we've got more videotape to prove
they're wrong and they're outright lying
take a look
surplus military equipment for law
enforcement they don't need that
the last thing you need is an up armored
humvee coming into a neighborhood it's
like the military invading
they don't know anybody they become the
enemy they're supposed to protecting
these people
so my generic point is do we agree that
we can redirect some of the funding
yes absolutely at least he didn't say
come on man
you're a junkie now just to recap the
radical socialist based of this new deal
democratic party demanded that the
police be defunded
they did it democratic leaders in the
house and the senate joe biden kamala
harris they all agreed
local democrats on the city-state level
then ripped billions of dollars
out of police budgets new york los
angeles and minneapolis that's just a
start
they reduce the size of their police
force they let
violent criminals out of jail they stop
prosecuting a multitude of
very serious crimes including violent
crimes and predictably
violent crime is skyrocketing and now
democrats they want to blame republicans
okay our memories might be short but
they're not that short
and the democratic party thinks that we
the american people
must be that gullible and stupid and at
the same time
this is the guy they just put in the
white house take a look
thank goodness for videotaping please
please please sit down
i once said that in the big crowd it was
in the evening
i said please sit down and there were no
seats they're out in the football field
and the press pointed out biden's losing
it
well i can see you all had seats this
bipartisan breakthrough is a great deal
for the american people
not just for folks in cities not just
for red states or blue states but for
everybody
this job this jobs
the jobs that are going to be created
here
largely would be those for blue collar
workers
this job this job
the job uh okay we've shown you tape
from
joe biden in 2012 2016. that seemed like
the same guy to you
you trust joe biden with your safety and
security you think he's going to come up
with a plan to reduce violent crime in
america
i don't think so we'll let you decide
joe biden
seemingly barely knows what day of the
week it is his radical
new green deals socialist base they seem
to be in charge
and make no mistake they are hell-bent
on dismantling law and order
we can tell by their actions hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else